so the first thing I would say and I do
tell parents this is just figure out
what it is that their kid is interested
in and also what are the kinds of things
that they may be struggling with so if
there's a child that is struggling with
a certain way of conceiving of complex
problems so maybe they're struggling in
math a little bit there's a lot of
different kinds of games that give kids
practice in ordering certain kinds of
problems working through kinds of
certain sequences of logic maybe there's
a kid that has a passion around sports
sports games are a great opportunity for
them to get in there and play with their
friends but also gain some facility
around the technology and so it mostly
has to do with trying to match an
interest that their child might have
with what a game might be offering not
just in terms of content but also in the
type of game so if you have a kid that
is let's say really interested in and
i'll go back to the math and engineering
there's a whole genre of games about
building stuff that might be a great
genre of game for that kid there may be
a kid that's really interested very
detail-oriented kind of type A
personality kid realtime strategy games
are a great zamora of games for those
kids and those are games where you are
managing complex that's a real resources
in a simulation environment and try to
advance toward a particular kind of goal
maybe you have a kid that's really
creative and interested in more
open-ended kind of exploration there's a
whole genre of adventure games that
might be really good for that particular
kind of child so it just really has to
do with what what the situation is
well the most important thing we know
from a learning is perspective is talk
so kids that grow up in households where
they don't have an opportunity to talk
with parents about what they're doing
the kids tend to struggle in many ways
because they haven't again been given
the opportunity to practice with the
language with using words with putting
together complex ideas with creating
arguments so the the simplest and
biggest thing a parent can do with the
child is sit down and play with them
play the game with them talk to them
about what they're doing prompt them ask
them questions kids love it when the
parent asks them to show that the kid
will show the parent how to do something
we have a program at the Institute of
play called play force where we bring in
kids from third grade up until college
and they play test games for us and they
tell us what they think are valuable
about the games and what we found is
with some of the younger kids that the
moms started coming in with the kids and
they would sit next to him and start to
play and there was a radical change in
the relationship a between the parents
understanding of what their kids were
learning from these games and be just in
the relationship between that parent and
child as the child became an expert in
explaining to the mom what they were
doing what they were learning how to
play the game and so that's a really
powerful role that you can put your
child in is letting them be the teacher
and letting them share with you what it
is that they find so interesting about
this thing that they're doing and it has
consequences in terms of their potential
for future learning